t
Paxlovid.
- - Bonsoir, Monsieur Morin.
- Bonsoir.tit
cours, ça commence avec à quoi
ça sert ce médicament
exactement?
- Ça sert à traiter le
positif dans un premier temps,
c'est la condition principale,
il faut avoir eu un résultat det
plus rapide. Il faut aussi avoir
des conditions de santé plus
particulière, par exemple êtreie
chronique ou avec l'âgé de
60 ans et plus. Si vous êtesné,-
dire de doses, que vous avez
quelques maladies chroniques,
vous n
vraiment les nonnt les nonnt len
premier et les gens à haut
risque d'hospitalisation, donc,
bien réagi au vaccin ou qui onts
précaires.
- Juste qu'on se comprenne bien
gens vaccinés mais qui ont
itions de santé
particulière, et peuvent aussi
avoir accès à c
- Pas pour la majorité d'entre
vous avait quelqu'un qui a reçu
c'est de doses quiu
diabète et qui a du cholestérol,
et n'est pas éligible à recevoir
immunosupprimé qu'il a eu de
doses, il pourra être éligible
parce qu'on n'est pas certain si
les vaccins ont bien fonctionné
tendresse en premier chez les
cinés qui, eux au-dessus
de 60 ans peuvent le recevoir
même s'il n'y a es. S'ils ont ds
maladies chroniques, en bas de
60 ans, ils peuvent recevoir le
Paxlovid.
des symptômes, on sait qu'on est
en a fait son test est-
ce que ça sert à rien?
- C'est pas en lie
symptômes, c'est une très bonne
question, c'est plutôt en lien
complications. Dès l'apparition
ômes que ômes que ômes que ômess
un test, il est positif, vous
appelez le pharmacien, vous Si s
êtes un groupe à risque, si vous
êtes pas adéquatement vacci
vous avez reçu seulement une
dose, vous avez le pharmacien et
vous pour faire une entrevue
r si vous r si vous r si vous re
recevoir parce qu'il y a quand
même beaucoup d'
avec d'autres médicaments. Il y
a mêmeactions majeures
qui vont vendre le traitement
impossible. Il faut valider
dans un premier temps. Le
pharmacien ce moment-là va faire
une prescription est envoyé
livraison.
- Vous ne vous présentez pas à
la pharmacie si vous avez un
test positif dans toutes les
dans un lieu public si vous êtes
symptomatique, vous restez à la
maison le temps de faire le
test.
- Effectivement, vous ne voulez
pas deveu de contau de contau dn
dans les pharmacies.
Si on attend trop avant deavante
pharmacien, on a u
on pensait que ça allait bien,
est-ce que il y a un moment  rie
les médicaments parce
qu'on a entendu trop longtemps?
le début des symptômes. Il faut
vraiment calculer cinq joursà là
partir du début des symptômes.
peine de faire le traitement, ça
ue plus les risques.
Mais posez-vous la question :
groupes à risques? Pour bien
faire lamoment voumoment voumoms
allez avoir votre résultat de
test posvous êvous êvous êvous ,
vous contactez le
parce que le plutôt que vous
allez faire le traitement, lid s
aider à guérir de la maladi
ses complications.
- S'informer un peu, y penser
même si on n'est pas malade pour
savoir si jamais on attrapait la
COVID, comment bien réagir, il
faut connaître son état de
santé, bien entendu. Peut-être
poser quelques questions.
- Connaître son statut vaccinal,
évidemment. Quand vous n'êtes
pas vacciné avec les deux doses,
il y a de bonnes choses que
vous faites parties du groupe
éligible.
- Merci.